[Music]  i'm harris faulkner and i've been with  fox news for 15 years  when you cover news every day you never  know when there's going to be that  certain story that just is a punch to  the gut one heartbreaking tragedy  and it hits the whole newsroom  at the same time it's raw it's emotional  it's unexpected that day the news moved  so quickly  and it was so heartbreaking i'm  anchoring and i see a hertz pull into  that  parking lot the whole newsroom took a  beat you could have heard a pin drop we  went live on the air  with my voice but that whole newsroom at  fox news was with me i couldn't have  done it without them  that is fox news  togetherness when it's good when it  counts and when it's tough  [Music]  you